there is an american skier eileen goo
who is competing for china in the
olympics
she was born and raised in san francisco
and she's not competing for america she
had the choice she could compete for
america or china she chose communist
china she said i've decided to compete
for china in the upcoming 2022 winter
olympics this was an incredibly tough
decision for me to make i'm extremely
thankful for u.s ski and snowboard and
the chinese ski association for having
the vision and belief in me to make my
dreams come true i'm proud of my
heritage and equally proud of my
american upbringing in
in other words thank you america for
raising me and giving me everything that
i have and and being the country that
formed me by
i'm going to go compete for communist
china now
which is fine i hope she has a nice time
in china and i hope she never comes back
that's her she's choosing
to represent that country she's saying
china is my country okay go live in
china
don't live here this is this isn't your
country then you've it's not me i didn't
kick you out you left so you go stay
there
if america is to have a future it needs
to be a real country it's got to have a
real flag
it's got to have real people that are
loyal to the country it's got to have a
common language it's got to have common
beliefs it's got to be it's got to have
common practices we can't have half the
country wearing secular kefia's the
stupid masks and half the country having
a completely different we've got to
agree on things okay we've got to have
shared words have shared symbols have a
real country with real borders if we
don't have that then we don't have a
nation if you want to give a meaningful
gift you've got to try paintyourlife.com
i love these guys you will get a
professional
hand-painted portrait created from any
photo
at an amazing price it's not even just
one photo you can combine photos of
people or places that you love into one
painting you choose from a team of
world-class artists and work with them
until every detail is perfect the
user-friendly platform makes it super
easy to order these custom made
hand-painted portraits in less than five
minutes it's really fast you can get
your portrait in as little as two weeks
they will work with you every step of
the way i am really picky
when it comes to art i'm really really
picky i was really skeptical of paint
your life when i first thought i said
there's no way you get a good so i i
first ordered one to give to my step
brother and then when i saw the final
product i thought oh my gosh this is
beautiful and then i started ordering
them myself i've got one hanging in my
living room they're just they're just
really really beautiful it's an amazing
gift for your loved ones or for yourself
paint yourlife.com there's no risk if
you don't love the final painting your
money is refunded guaranteed as a
limited offer right now get 20 off your
painting that's 20 off and free shipping
to get this offer text the word michael
to sixty four thousand text it right now
m-i-c-h-a-e-l to sixty-four thousand
paint your life celebrate the moments
that matter most terms apply available
paint your life dot com slash terms
again that is michael text it to 64 000.
i'm glad that you liked that clip
i like that you like that clip
if you want to get more clips you got to
ring that bell you got to subscribe get
the notifications if you don't get the
notifications for whatever reason
youtube then you should head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe to the michael
knowles show podcast leave a five star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you